we're going to begin with the story that
you've been waiting for I've definitely
been waiting for it it's our annual
Super Bowl City Showdown his favorite
story of the year I think it features
the home towns of the Super Bowl teams
and two of our Saturday morning co-host
Dana Jacobson back in the Kansas City
Chiefs and Michelle Miller representing
the Philadelphia Eagles you know we have
talked all morning already about this
history making matchup featuring two
black starting quarterbacks and then two
brothers on opposite teams Jason Kelsey
and this guy Travis Kelsey yeah well
Dana that 87 Jersey you're wearing is
actually in honor of Jason's birth month
and their mom says that Jason bleeds
Philadelphia well in Kansas City we all
bleed red and the history of the Chiefs
and the Super Bowl that runs deep they
were in the very first Super Bowl back
in 1967. this is their fifth appearance
in the big game and I'm going out on a
limb it's going to be their third win
you're getting a little ahead of
yourself there DJ odds May acres in
Vegas have the Philadelphia Eagles as
the favorite so all I'm going to say is
Fly Eagles
fly
welcome to the City of Brotherly Love
we're in Fairmount Park the largest
urban park in the country where the
Eagles are back in the Super Bowl for
the first time since 2018.
[Music]
and I hope you're ready because we are
flying high up here at the top of
Philadelphia go first turns
[Music]
we'll check out this bird's eye view
Michelle of the Kansas City skyline
the Chiefs are headed to their third
Super Bowl in four years so yeah I like
their chances and so do these guys Lewis
and Clark who famously explored the west
and just happened to Camp right here
along the banks of the mighty Missouri
which you know Michelle just happens to
be the longest river in the U.S don't
even get me started on Rivers DJ I mean
here in Philly we've got the Delaware
you might remember the guy who famously
crossed it
please I wonder if George Washington
would like the Kansas city-style
barbecue that Mary here is cooking up
because we have so much to get to
between the Kansas and Missouri borders
it's a really good thing that they've
got this vending machine here at Jones's
barbecue in fact I am going to take a
burnt end sandwich to go
[Music]
if you want to talk famous sandwiches
you got to grab yourself a classic
Philly cheesesteak hey Maximo can I have
some extra with it's so good even our
cameraman couldn't resist she's steak
how about a strip steak we're at the
Golden Ox we're back in 1949 they gave
birth to the Kansas City strip steak
um
true on that
I'd rather chew on this double bubble
gum created right here in Philadelphia
sorry to burst your bubble Michelle but
Kansas City is also home to its own
Confections Russell Stover the
chocolatier is headquartered here talk
about brotherly love
and in our Tale of Two Cities only one
has a giant wall of literary Classics
well Philadelphia was home to author
Edgar Allan Poe famous for writing
chilling works like the Ravens Ravens
and Eagles no thanks we've got plenty of
birds here at the Kansas City Zoo over
80 species and bluebird I'm pretty sure
you guys are are all chiefs fans right
[Music]
you're making me a little peckish now
Dana and since we're in the birthplace
of the American pretzel
time for me to take a bite out of them
[Music]
invented by the Pennsylvania Dutch
more than 200 years ago
yeah yeah we have soft pretzels too and
here at the Kansas city Pretzel Boys
they even custom designed theirs how
about them
oh yeah
if you want to support the Eagles
climbing a land pole is a Time tester
tradition
this Lamppost and clock arrived in the
1880s Michelle talk about time tested
sure but when it comes to history Philly
is the place to be the Founding Father
signed the Declaration of Independence
right here in 1776 and this square is
named after a pretty famous One how's it
going back there Ben very well Madam go
Birds Kansas City has presidential ties
too Harry Truman was raised right here
in nearby Independence Kansas City is
also home to the National World War One
Museum and Memorial and it turns out
this is where the NFL is holding its
2023 Draft
when it comes to sports Philly has kcb
[Music]
this season not only did they make it to
the World Series and the MLS Cup final
but Philly is an official 2026 FIFA
World Cup host
sorry Michelle but uh Kansas City here
at Arrowhead Stadium is also a FIFA host
how about this 2700 square foot mural
right outside the eagle's nest
every year the Eagles players work with
mural Arts Philadelphia to pave part of
a mural for the community this one's
called our city
RT this Jazz mural is one of several
here in Kansas City paying tribute to
its musical routes
the smooth sound even serves as the
backdrop to a classic Robert Altman film
named after this very Town come on Dana
you can't talk about classic films and
not mention Rocky please
but after all that I'm thinking I'm kind
of a Cree girl you know uh
hmm
how about that Michael B Jordan
sure he's dreaming but Chief's Kingdom
has some star power too Jason Sudeikis
and Paul Rudd their Chiefs super fans
all right Dana but let's bring it back
to game day and this year it is on
it's the first time in Super Bowl
history that we have two brothers
competing it's Kelsey versus Kelsey and
over here at mcgillin's one of the
oldest bars in the country it is team
Jason
all the way they also eat and drink
green cheers everybody
well we're seeing red here at Town Topic
word is it's one of Chief's head coach
Andy Reed's favorite spots for his
favorite food he's always loved a good
cheeseburger but when he was coaching in
Philly thanks he never had a chance to
toast a Super Bowl victory with one that
didn't happen Tilly came here
cheeseburgers are Paradise baby eat up
Michelle
okay all right I like it I like it do
you have a determination on who the
winner is on this one uh no I just want
to know the behind the scenes of how you
did it wow because the it's a whole crew
of people absolutely Brian Bingham
Natasha Singh I had uh Vito y spawn
that's right we have Michael sugar
yes so were you calling her saying what
you were saying and you were no no it's
all mapped out you gotta map out where
you're going figure it out and it's and
it's a record
until what two weeks out and then a week
ahead we figured out on Sunday we were
shooting on Thursday Craig Shays the
master editor who puts it then together
and marries it two weeks out from the
Super Bowl but yeah we do it in less
than four days we are all winners yes
terrifically talented team I think what
do you think however I'm going to go
ahead and say uh-oh and this is
objective Kansas City is the winner it's
a city he says your piece wasn't
terrific your side was wonderful but the
barbecue in Kansas City Missouri is out
okay okay let me just say this I'm going
to fault our boo our boo Brian Bingham
for this because like the Philadelphia
fans Brian's gonna be mad at me
Philadelphia fans were like on my case
about the roast pork sandwich
anywhere they want you to live in a Wawa
Wawa right and of course so that's
everyone's like Philly cheesesteak oh
that's so cliche I've never had Philly
cheese but hey when Philly's in after
they win this year and they're back next
year up against our Saints is that
possible AFC and FC come on Saints
they're really in the safe Camp they can
play in the championship let me say this
let's have a close game well we can
agree all right all right ladies y'all
were great that was terrific